ladies and gentlemen
sorry we had a han dynasty chinese food
and it's spicy and uh
ben loves chinese food it's his favorite
kind of food it makes him feel
very few things do
um
and you would say it's your favorite
food by far thai food uh more than
chinese food uh i would say it's chinese
and then japanese kind of in a thai
right there interesting it's all east
coast i mean east eastern eastern world
yes
phenomenal
that's great i like chinese i don't you
know i mean i'm uh you know
i don't
i don't know it's not my favorite you
know
because i'm a civilized person
so i don't eat chicken feet and stuff
but i don't mind it i like countries
with tablecloths
um
welcome to the alt-right nazi food hour
[Laughter]
uh thank you for coming and uh this is
when we
uh we're i'm watching a show on hbo
right now called the gilded age which
isn't good but it's not bad
and it's about all these uh old money
families in new york that um
are being displaced by new money
families and it's about like
um a family that's supposed to be the
vanderbilts because it's a railroad
tycoon and his wife and they're trying
to break into
old new york and um
you see in the show how bad the irish
had it you know everybody we always hear
about you know
uh
you know
slaves but we never hear about irish
slaves
and there were like a ton of them
and that's what my podcast is now about
telling the story of irish slaves
um but you know one of the maids is
irish she's like a gambler and a guy's
just beating her up and throwing her on
the street trying to get his money but
now you know hbo has got to force all
these story lines they got to force
diversity so you have like a black
character who
you know it's just you're watching this
thing a girl gets robbed
the black lady lends their money and
then she goes to this
you know rich uh family in new york and
then they just take her in
so here's what you have to believe now
you have to believe that america was
this stunningly racist
horrible society which there's a lot of
merit to that belief but you also have
to suspend that belief
to to enjoy a show
where they just move a black woman into
the home
within two days of meeting her because
you need the diversity
in this show
so it's like the craziest storyline ever
it's like oh yeah she lent me money to
get on the train
and then she gets there and they're like
oh you can dictate my letters you can
read or write live with us
live with us and be a principal
character on the show
and that's where the diversity start
going it's odd
i'm all for having another black family
on the show in brooklyn
where it's believable where it's not
like you're not forcing this thing that
would really
just never happen
in in my estimation i'm not saying it's
never happened but the idea you have
this old money new york rich family just
taking in
uh this black girl after knowing her for
less than 24 hours ago just live here
just live here
it's odd
you know but again this is what this is
part of the new
ethos in hollywood where even if it
doesn't make sense
just do it
just throw it in
and no shade to anybody
hey
get your money i'd rather watch a show
where there's a black family
experiencing truly what it was like
in that era
than that forced storyline
uh that we're seeing which clearly seems
to be
uh
not what would have happened or maybe
i'm wrong
but it doesn't seem to be
like that the whole show is about this
woman being terribly uncomfortable with
her white neighbor that's the entire
show is about these two women who are
just you know once old money wants new
money and they don't get along the new
money one is garrish and vulgar she's a
vulgarian and the old money one
christine baranski doesn't like her no
we're supposed to believe that she's
terribly uncomfortable
uh with uh but she moves in the black
girl uh in under 24 hours and goes come
live in a house late 1800s by the way
civil war is ended hours ago
and we're supposed to believe she just
oh just come on in the house
the whole show is about she hates
different classes of white people who
have money
they have more money than her it's not
even about it's it's just the whole show
is about how you hate the other
like you just there are people are
tribal by nature and people hate
disruptions and they hate change
and she hates this woman who lives
across the street who has real money
and her husband's er this you know brash
railroad tycoon who's a
you know a big money player in new york
and she's terribly uncomfortable with
that and she doesn't like it
but
she moves into black girl and we're
supposed to just
you know
kind of ease past that
what seems to be a glaring
contradiction because hbo needs
to do that now
and you go
okay
all right
it's also whatever the shows went out
nobody asked for the show
either
nobody was like you know we
because the guy made it to downton abbey
which a lot of people loved my
grandmother loved it which was like a
show about
british aristocracy
and
he's doing it for america for new york
but
you know nobody was
pounding
on the door saying please god
make a show about this
and not only have they made a show about
it but they've made a show about it
where
one of the key plot points to me
feels a bit ludicrous
or maybe it wasn't that racist
maybe those old white women who lived on
fifth avenue weren't that bad
that's kind of what you have to deduce
you have to go she's not that bad
she lives a black girl live in a house
that's lovely
i'm sure that's not
a common thing
again it's
you can't have it both ways you know
oh the country is was horribly racist
i'm with you there i agree with that i
think you're right about that
but this old [ __ ]
loved this black woman
and moved her in under 24 hours having
not even known her
moved her right in
oh
and that's the show just
just go with it
just go with the show and you go okay
i was reading about
you know i'm trying to you know the
the the diet that we're all being fed
right that was war
it's just a steady diet of ukraine
war
and
it's unhealthy
it's unhealthy
the tv just went on
it's unhealthy to just hear about the
war i'm not saying it's un unimportant
i'm not saying it doesn't matter i'm
saying there's how many explosions
should you watch
it's a fair point it's a fair question
right
how many buildings
should you watch being shelled
before you have coffee
four
because we are now being fed
a steady
war
diet
the troops are advancing they are they
may launch an amphibious assault on
odessa
they are in the black sea
the convoy has been stalled on the way
to kiev
which everyone is pronounced kiev and
now it is kiev whatever
uh are people on twitter are fighting is
vladimir putin a rational actor
acting in his self-interest
after being goaded into the war by the
expansion of nato
there's something to that for sure
certainly
and the other side or is vladimir putin
a psychopath
who's uh behaving erratically
um which there's also room for that
because when you look at what he's gonna
have to do with ukraine have a military
presence there for a long time bleed his
country there uh bleed his country drive
financially
have
uh you know
to deal with an insurgency
for as long as they're there ukrainians
are never going to forget about this
it's not like he could just install a
puppet government and be done
this is a real project we just got done
with this in iraq and afghanistan how
did it work out for us we were
humiliated
the taliban came back
20 years later
but a lot of people made a lot of money
in that period i'm not you know naive
but these things don't usually work
um
so a cost-benefit analysis of this but i
think he was like listen
i'm in my 70s there's rumors that he has
parkinson's he's like hey
he's concerned with his legacy he goes
i'm not going to let you put missiles
all around russia i'm just not going to
do it i'm a nuclear power we have more
nuclear warheads than anybody else i'm
going to act like it
there's a great line in succession what
good is having [ __ ] you money if you
can't say [ __ ] you
and i think putin goes well what good is
having all these goddamn nukes
just so what i could talk to oliver
stone
no i want a party too america's running
around the middle east pretending
they're democratizing things and they
ain't
you know
israel's you know with palestine the
whole thing
saudi arabia is doing a genocide
genocide in yemen
why don't i get
involved
i feel like you know he feels like hey
you're not gonna put me in a box
but we so we have that
um
reality now that being said he's invaded
a country and uh it's uh
it's
terrible to watch right now a lot of
americans don't
seem to feel
uh any which way about the people that
are being killed in fact some of them
think it's a good thing
or that the putin is doing something to
be cheered on like you would cheer on
the dallas cowboys
and they are um saying that vladimir
putin isn't your enemy which is okay
sure but who is my enemy i mean why why
does there need to be an enemy
all the time
because
inherent in vladimir putin isn't your
enemy is that okay it's kamala harris is
your anime
you go well okay
can i live in a world where i'm not in
direct conflict with either vladimir
putin or kamala harris
because i'm trying new kamala has more
effect on my life she could raise my
taxes
she could do things that i don't like
um that being said i'd rather live here
in america than live in moscow
which people have forgotten
i think somehow
somewhere
people have forgotten that they go
well
no america's got a lot of problems too
yeah
pound for pound though it would be hard
to really make the argument that you'd
be better off
living
in russia
i mean i know you're maybe upset about
what's happening in the country you
don't like certain things
critical race theories you know got you
bent out of shape
you know whatever drag queens you know
red uh the cat in the hat in the library
that's keeping you up
[Music]
you know what i mean
you know there's not enough diversity in
the marvel movie franchise on the other
side whatever your problems happen to be
it's probably
pound for pound
still better to live here
not maybe by that much and maybe not for
much longer depending on how we go
but when you hear people talk about this
idea
there seems to be this idea that you
know where it's the debate is kind of um
about
you know
like
that we
the the cia
and america has done bad things
which we are well aware of we've had all
of this on the show we've been
completely aware that we are an empire
in the stage of decline
that empire was established by cia coos
military conquest
as all empires are i mean we're very
aware of this right there's been no
empire in history that's ever gotten
uh to the size we are or any
approximation of it without doing all
those things it's just not the way
empires are built
that doesn't excuse them that doesn't
make them right
um
but there is a weird idea or strange
idea
that
everything russia does which is uh a bad
thing
has to be immediately countered
by reminding people that we've also done
a bad thing
it's like an interesting kind of a
knee-jerk
whereas if putin were to go in and nuke
ukraine tomorrow
people would tweet well
we also dropped the atom bomb on japan
i don't know what that
does
i don't know what that accomplishes i i
don't know what where that
i don't know but it's people are very
it's kind of people if if nukes came
flying over here there'd be a fair
amount of the population that went and
he's right
good for him
like i mean would they stop at that
that's a fair point if putin were to
invade america which he's not going to
do
but if he were to do that would there be
a a a segment of the population that
goes
good
good for him
i don't know
i'm not saying it's
it just does feel like it's a little bit
of a knee-jerk reaction
where a lot of the stuff coming out of
the ukraine is propaganda for
sure we know that
is it yeah and is it dangerous
propaganda
perhaps if it
needlessly escalates the war
where these neocon warhawks are like
let's just enforce no-fly zones and
which is essentially an act of war
yeah
i'm all for
not being taken in by like
war propaganda
you know
but i i don't personally need to fact
check
every single inspirational
story
that comes out of the ukraine like i
don't i don't personally
like when that goes to kiev thing
happened i didn't i don't care
if it goes to kiev as a wheeler whatever
they need to believe right they're
getting bombed whatever they need to be
you want to believe in a ghost kiev the
ghost of christmas past it none of it
means anything to me people in this
country believe in all kinds of [ __ ]
they believe in monsters
cannibals you know like people believe
in jesus people believe in
all kinds of stuff
is that i don't care if they believe it
or not it's great good for you but if
you want to believe in the ghost of kiev
i don't care it doesn't really affect me
now
if you start to see the propaganda go in
a direction where you can kind of see it
moving where it's like
well i think we should do more
then you go hold on
calm down
relax
i i am not for doing more
we i am for doing the same or less
because
we're not we shouldn't be getting into a
war with russia over this not our fight
i just don't i don't see the value
in like fact-checking every
little thing
that comes out of the ukraine
where they're like putin they got into
some firefight at a nuclear plant and
everybody's like it's fine
the nuclear plan is fine
everyone's freaking out over it but it's
actually good
and you go oh okay
but what is this
how far will this go
you know
the orphanage putin bond was actually a
secondary school the kids were four to
seven
okay
well it's different because it's not an
orphanage you said it was babies they're
eight
okay i understand that well i'm just
saying
get your facts straight
oh
yeah well all right
but again i understand like if that
propaganda
is being used to justify
a more of a direct conflict with russia
then then yeah [ __ ] it no
that should be off the table that's off
the table
we're not doing that it's off the table
so i understand like
i understand like figuring out what's
what i just don't see the need
for myself
to
like you know zielinski uh there were
three assassination attempts yeah maybe
not
okay but
in your own head why wouldn't the
russians be trying to assassinate him
right just think about it like why
wouldn't they
if you were put would you not want him
dead
i don't you know
he's doing a pretty good job of
galvanizing support behind the cause
so wouldn't you want him out of the
picture well they said three it was two
get your fat straight
you go i understand
the impulse
to to to distrust
media narratives i think it's important
to have
and
i've done it my entire life with 9 11
with all these things
um
but in this case it just feels again
like everything is a as a domestic
politics
like the big problem with the conspiracy
movement was it got fused with domestic
politics it used to be
people that were really well read who
knew a lot about history
questioning conclusions
and doing it in a very like you know
pretty
bookish
way
um
they were pretty meticulous
and they read a lot
and then the conspiracy movement through
q anon became fused with domestic
politics the horse race
you know i'm gonna win i'm gonna beat
you
and then a lot of people started to get
uh interested in these topics who had
never read a book and didn't know
anything and were completely unaware of
uh what disinformation was and were
completely unaware of yes there is human
trafficking going around but maybe the
human traffickers are the ones pushing
these stories that uh their cannibals
and their uh boiling kids and pots and
maybe they're doing that because it
actually seems so fantastical that it
makes people dismiss
the actual reality
of human trafficking
as uh it relates to political elites in
america so when you're talking about
chrissy teigen
running a cult of witches eating
children people are
easily dismissed that but you took him
in epstein and you talk about things
like that and there's facts
now it's much harder to dismiss so a lot
of that weird this and i'm not saying
that the weird people in this country
don't do occult [ __ ] and don't murder
kids or whatever but i'm saying as this
grand conspiracy that q anon became
it actually did more to hurt
legitimate concerns and questions
about human trafficking because it was
all about winning so about the domestic
political impulse of seeing your enemies
get smashed seeing them lose
and this was of course seeing them get
locked up putting guantanamo bay
executed
so
looking at this war
and making it about joe biden or donald
trump
or making it about how to win
against somebody else that disagrees
with you
about
something seems to be
the it just seems to be very limiting
it's limiting in the scope of human
experience the way to look at things the
way to analyze things you shouldn't
necessarily
hear something and then immediately leap
to
okay but how does this serve my overall
goal
of making my neighbor look stupid
you should look at it and try to form
opinions outside of that
outside of that impulse
i try to check that impulse all the time
it kills humor it kills creativity it
kills being good at your job
i mean unless you just want to be a hack
partisan
is shoving slop down people's throat
which is how many people earn great
livings but if you don't want to do that
you shouldn't
that's why everybody's like oh you're
essential so you're never too good
i whatever you want to call it i i don't
care what you people think truly i have
enough money i could quit tomorrow ben
would have to work but i don't
um and he's young and he can get a job i
don't care what any of you think
uh if i did i never would have done this
show because everybody told me it was a
waste of my time and then i should just
you know do a food show on comedy
central and be the next anthony bourdain
and go to places and uh talk to the
diner waitress and uh you know do that
or to do a travelogue do a travel show
you go around and
talk to people and you know go to the
fair
uh but no we we we did this show so i
don't give a [ __ ] with you people think
it doesn't matter
i barely care what i think
and i make a lot of money
thinking
you know we have a lot of fun about
bitcoin here i'm a comedian it's kind of
my job to talk [ __ ] not give investing
advice so when i get serious to talk
about overlooked alternative asset
that's not nfts or crypto you know it's
special i'm talking about blue chip art
that's right the [ __ ] that usually hangs
on walls and museums and today's sponsor
masterworks
makes it possible for you to invest in
blue chip art without being a
billionaire here's how it works
masterworks offers an investment in
multi-million dollar pieces of artwork
works by icons like banksy or picasso so
you can go out and invest in a painting
without paying 103 million
which is how much a picasso sold for
last year in new york why do the super
rich spend that much on one painting it
could be because art pieces outpace the
s p 500 by 164 percent from 1995 to
2020.
nothing funny about those numbers they
didn't get rich by being stupid
and my friends over at masterworks are
giving my listeners priority access to
their latest offerings at masterworks
dot art slash tim it's a good idea
to invest in art truly
and a lot of people do not have the
capital obviously to buy a painting
outright so what masterworks is allowing
people are you paying attention to me
what they're allowing people to do is
invest in the art
it's really amazing
my friends at masterworks are really
making this happen for you
masterworks dot art slash tim
see the important disclaimers at
masterworks
dot io slash disclaimer
ben is using lucy nicotine and he's
really good he hasn't had a cigarette
forever look we're all adults here i
know some of us choose nicotine to relax
focus or unwind after a long day lucy is
a modern oral nicotine company that
makes nicotine gum lozenges and pouches
for adults who are looking for the best
most responsible way to consume their
nicotine it's a new year why not start
it up by switching to a new nicotine
product that you could feel good about
okay ben loves it it's great right
yeah i love all the flavors of the
lozenges uh if you using nicotine you
should definitely check out lucy's
products at lucy.co that's lucy.co and
use promo code tim at checkout
and warning this product contains
nicotine nicotine is an addictive
chemical remember if you're interested
in a better way to use nicotine visit
lucy.co
and use the promo code t-i-m
lucy.co use a promo code t-i-m so
basically i don't use loose anymore lucy
weaned me off of cigarettes and nicotine
completely which is the whole idea
behind the company lucy lucy
i love lucy and that was a show
on television i love lucy and it was a
hilarious show at lucille ball who was
kind of a racist but that came out later
it's fun to be able to use nicotine in a
fun way
lucy
you've got back-to-back meetings aaron's
toronto and chores to take care of
what's the secret to clearing your to-do
list a little help from doordash
you get dinner household essentials and
everything on your grocery list
delivered ever pulled into the driveway
after a trip to the grocery store only
to realize that you forgot one key
ingredient for dinner now you have
options get the groceries you need or a
backup meal from your favorite local
restaurant delivered with doordash what
do you want to eat tonight maybe a
home-cooked favorite but don't feel like
going to the store or you want something
exciting and new but it'd be great to
stay in doordash connects you with
everything you want whenever and however
you want it but really here's a cool
thing
for a limited time our listeners can get
25
off and zero delivery fees on their
first order of 15 or more which is
everything you order when you download
the doordarshan app and enter code tim
dillon
download the doordash app enter code tim
dillon okay that's 25 off up to ten
dollar value and zero delivery fees on
your first order when you download the
doordash app and enter code tim dillon
so it's an amazing service but even on
top of that you're saving money
hello
door dash you don't have to go to the
store they do it
you don't have to cook dinner
they do it
that's what makes it good they do it for
you
it shows up at your home
piping hot
ready to be consumed
or the groceries show up and you could
cook
uh a nice romantic dinner with your
lover
doordash it's good
to do
it's much better than going to the store
it's dangerous on the roads and people
at the store losing their minds
what you need to do is just stay away
from everybody all the time
i use doordash because it's fun and easy
i go out and people recognize me all the
time they tell me that i've changed
their life
it's fun for a while but it gets
annoying especially when i'm trying to
get pancake mix
anyway
go to door dash and use the code tim
dillon 25 off your first order for a
limited time subject to change terms
apply
but i try to look at both people like i
i try to look at both sides of an issue
and go
where
are
people correct in my estimation and
where are they wrong so i get checking
propaganda and i get that propaganda
being dangerous if it's used to force
more of a direct conflict with russia
right
but then of course i see that that can
go overboard too that can get a little
silly
you know that just seems it could get a
little silly
right
like for example if putin just launches
nuclear strikes in four or five
different countries that he's not going
to do this but let's say he did you know
would people well it's the expansion of
nato yeah maybe but hey we're in a
different place now
let's try to think about how to survive
here
you know
you don't have any survival instinct
well it's well you know we shouldn't
have done
yeah well hey you know
it's like you're in a bad situation you
know some guy's got a gun in the back of
your head you're in a bad part of the
city and you know one of your friends
like she goes we never should have came
here it's like hey this is not helping
this doesn't really help at the present
moment i don't know how bad things are
going to get
you know
you know i mean
i'm hoping that this car i mean i'm
bored of it already if that's a good
sign
i hope it's a good sign it's it's become
boring to me
i don't really want to keep watching
this
it was fun for a few days because it was
like new and interesting but it's really
become
to be honest dull
and people's takes are are already
becoming circular you've heard them they
keep you know
you know
you know i'm getting wary of the
sing-songy [ __ ] on one side about
how like
new zelinsky and all this stuff like i'm
getting wary of that because that's my
nature to be like wait a minute hold on
where are we going and then on the other
side where people are just literally
putting putin's [ __ ] in their mouth and
sucking them off on tv is also slightly
so i don't know where i just turn it off
got to turn it off
you know all these dumb things that we
do you know the you know i was in long
island the other day and
there was a sign you know the town of
babylon stands with ukraine it's like
that type of [ __ ] of course it's like
cringe
you look at that stuff you go what the
[ __ ] this gonna do but what else are
we gonna do
what the [ __ ] else are you gonna do you
just go yeah well the town of babylon
stands at ukraine and by the way i've
been in babylon they probably don't
that's the other thing i don't know if i
don't know if they took a poll i don't
know who the [ __ ] put up that sign
but it's just uh
you know i'm getting tired of it
i'm getting tired of it we're supposed
to be out of this
we're supposed to be getting out of a
pandemic and then there's supposed to be
some type of creative renaissance this
is what i've been and i don't mean
uh in a good way i mean like a very dumb
silly stupid
uh you know
spate of film projects that come out
where
it's like people are like really goofy
and like
nothing has a plot
and everybody just kind of so happy to
be out of their house and
they just don't you know care
anymore
and um
that's what i was picturing not a a war
we're like in like we're in war mode and
i'm just like i can't
i can't get in i just can't get into it
i can't get into it
does that sound [ __ ] perhaps
but what do you want me to do force it i
can't force it like hbo is forcing the
storyline
i can't force myself into you know we
did it we had the guy on the show
and we listened to david bowie's heroes
in the car and we drove over the 59th
street bridge and then we went to have
bagels we did it
we did what we were there to do
he came on he told his tale
and we supported my donated 5 000 of
bitcoin to him
and uh he sent me a few photos of like
charred russian bodies i guess which i i
wanted photos of something else which i
don't think he got i think it was a
language barrier for five thousand
dollars i wanted other but whatever
doesn't matter we wish him well we wish
him the best but you know we did a
heroic thing for ukraine by having him
on a show
uh you know that's ad supported and we
made a lot of money to do but
i i'm kind of now i've reached the point
now where i go okay i just
i wanna you know we're heading into the
spring in the summer and i just you know
we don't need gas being a million
trillion dollars
we just don't need it we don't need it
enough with the sanctions
let's calm down with the sanctions
because here's the deal
it's about to impact all of us in ways
we don't like
airfare going up
price of gas
going up
we're trying to have a summer here
i'm talking like this no one everyone's
afraid to say these things i'm gonna say
them
and by the way i don't mean that because
there's a lot of people saying them
by the way it should be taboo like what
i'm saying should be taboo but i believe
it's being pretty openly uh discussed in
congress
but i i i do believe we got to look out
for ourselves a little bit here
and i just think we can't really go too
crazy with the sanctions
what if we did what if we lifted the
sanctions on putin
and said hey
what if
what is it you catch more flies with
honey than you do with vinegar
what if we lifted the sanctions
i mean
as a as a show of good faith
i'm not a geopolitical mastermind
whatever is a show of good faith
lift the sanctions
and go
hey
do we got to do
but just you know take care of us here
we need to get the price of fuel
down
it's a fact
from new york city
get
how many miles is it from new york city
to the hamptons
how many miles
it is let's see here
sorry
it is exactly 94 miles
okay it's a hundred miles let's round it
okay it is a hundred miles
of gas how many miles to the gallon
are people getting on average like
on that highway probably like 18. 18
miles to the gallon so how many gallons
of gas about five or six we're looking
at about five or six gallons and gas is
what now
uh
about four i mean it's about four
yeah people are bracing for five that's
what's coming so every time you go to
hampton's about 30 bucks
yeah five gallons there five gallons
back you're looking at sixty yeah that's
sixty dollars for one trip to the
hamptons
sixty dollars
now that's for the people that drive
then we have helicopters
we have private planes yes no i mean
this is
right right hey here's the reality here
no this is i'm not
i'm not
here
to pretend
that things aren't how they are
this is a big problem heading into the
summer
people are going to want to go to europe
they're going to want to travel i have a
lot of friends that
are gonna be in martha's vineyard and
maybe they're gonna be in nantucket
fairies you know what i mean like guys
what are we what
like
are you willing to trade your summer
for ukraine
no no no i'm dead serious
are you willing to trade your summer for
the ukraine
i'm talking about the summer of love the
summer of [ __ ] covet is finally over
facts mandates have dropped everybod i'm
talking partying outside
i mean eating a [ __ ] that tastes like
peach melba the
summer i'm talking about
warm summer breezes
i mean are you willing
to not
participate in a lot of those activities
because of the ukraine
and
i don't know i don't think i am
so i believe right now
we need to lift all the sanctions on
putin
until the fall
because and and he'll still be there we
just answered him in the fall
i
i just let's be honest
you know
where were you going to go this summer
carve was that where you were going to
go
were you going to go to carve
were you
are you going to go to malibu
let's
start looking out
for number one
we didn't get to be the greatest country
in the world by taking care of other
people
let's be honest and maybe you might not
believe
we're the greatest country in the world
that's absolutely fine
but we didn't get here
by concern for others
as twitter will tell you
so it's time to stop pretending that we
have we got to cut it out now
cut it out stop the flags
stop the songs
stop the song and dance routine
cut it out we've done it now for a week
i know we don't you know our our movies
suck nobody respects us anymore we don't
even put out good [ __ ] everything we
make is horrible every comedian special
that comes out on hbo not all of them
but a lot of them it's just somebody on
a stage talking about how sad they are
without a goddamn joke
the the rest of the world has figured us
out
okay we [ __ ] up we haven't put out a
good movie in a long [ __ ] time
there's not [ __ ] to watch we used to
bomb the hell out of these people rape
and pillage but we used to give them
good [ __ ]
great movies okay ghostbusters and
seinfeld and scent of a woman whatever
they loved it you know rap music black
culture all these things we exported all
over the world
everything we do now sucks
we don't have any soft power that's
worth a damn
so just shut it down lift the sanctions
on putin lift them on putin let's have a
summer it's time to have a summer
whether you're a poor piece of [ __ ]
trash bag who gets drunk in a lake or
you got a little scratch and you find
your way to one of the [ __ ] oceans in
this country somewhere whatever
not my business
everybody deserves a [ __ ] summer
after the two years we've had and that
involves immediately lifting the
sanctions on vladimir putin i'm sorry i
apologize
but i'm i i there's no other way out
here
lift the [ __ ] sanctions
i'm talking gas
289 not even
let's start cutting deals here's the
deal we're gonna feel bad if we lift the
sanctions we're gonna feel horrible
because he's gonna
use all that money to go in there and i
mean god what he's gonna do but
that's why the gas has to be so cheap
the deal has to be so good
i mean i'm talking about what what can
we get it down to 210 it's gotta be so
good
that you're eating that burger and the
summer breeze is hitting you in the face
and everybody's got their tits and dicks
out and everybody's having fun and you
just you don't you feel a little bad but
not that bad because the deal's got to
be good for us to turn
away from this to look away
and remove all sanctions we got to get a
good deal on fuel
good deal
so that we can go have a summer
the world is going to be uninhabitable
in i don't know seven years
enjoy
what you
have enjoy what you have now
so this is my and again it is not
it is not the most you know
you know
it's not a position that makes me proud
that i have it
i'm not proud of it
but
do you see another way out
so do you see another way out of this
here's here's how you see a way out
here's why i like it here's why i like
it yeah i like it here's why i like it
because
if if they're going to occupy for 10 or
15 years hey we come back in the fall
and we sanction them
we or not because we got to do [ __ ] then
too the fall is amazing
people want to do a weekend in the
berkshires listen
can we cut it out with this
stop with this
have a summer
i mean i mean this is this is what we
got to do
this is what we got to do there's
there's no other way around this here
and this is unfortunate
when is this we should i guess do we
have to just put this out as the main
one because if we put it as a patreon
when's that supposed to go out
uh that would be
in six days from now so if there's like
new clear things so we have to put this
out as the main one yeah
audio only
yeah what are you gonna do hey [ __ ] you
you don't like
who cares
but i am i am saying right now
we should absolutely without a doubt
remove all sanctions on vladimir putin
and commend him on securing the ukraine
from nazis now there are some nazis over
there that azov azoff that's their elite
fighting force that they are all not can
we call the great i'm going to call the
great melanie here let's see if she
answers because there's no one funnier
than her quite frankly and she did sum
this up kind of brilliantly the other
day and by the way some people listened
from ukraine and i i i'm very sorry
about this but we just deserve a summer
hello hey melanie how are you
hey what's up man listen you're you're
on the podcast
let let me ask you know more you know
more about everyday
putin we all know putin's a psychopath
but aren't the ukrainians also like kind
of nazis
yeah they're like white supremacists and
all of a sudden he loves them
they are kind of nazis though yeah
they're partners one of the one of the
guys that like what's his face byron's
hand like shaking hands with is like you
know a total nazi
and people forget it too it's like oh
well you know
they're
they're they're they're nazis but
they're not as bad as the russians right
right you know it's convenient
right for sure i don't know what i don't
know why this is all even happening
but it's not going to egg well i can
tell you that i mean if you know what
putin's not gonna lose he's just gonna
push the button at the end
right he's not gonna but i'm just saying
listen i wanna keep gas cheap because i
i think we all just have a nice summer
oh god dude let me tell you something
yeah exactly but the gas situation uh
which recall putin has i think it's
about
i i would say between
at least almost 30 percent of the market
coming in and he's you know he's
exporting almost all the natural gas to
germany that's why you're seeing such a
tempted response on you on ukraine from
all these countries they're like yeah we
want to help but we want to eat food you
know we don't want to like you know pay
a zillion dollars for like heat and all
this other stuff especially here you
mean yeah we just i i think i i don't
know what we're gonna what we have to do
here but like you know i'm i'm not into
going into a nuclear war for the ukraine
no me neither i need or no no oh as uh
uh i would say the uranium which i
thought was hysterical yeah well he's of
course no no nuclear war uh what should
we call it he uh
god i mean i mean at the gas like right
now everybody's like the poor ukraine
but but uh if it goes up to like you
know eight or nine dollars a gallon
they're gonna go to war with them you
know what i mean
you know what that's [ __ ] that's
probably what will happen is the gas
will go up to about seven dollars a
gallon in like ten dollars in california
and we'll sneak a bomb in there to just
end it and blame it on the russians
it may be the best uh thing to do
of course i mean
we just have to do it all right i'll
call you later babe thank you so much we
appreciate it
it's a great melanie again it's rare
that someone has moral clarity in these
times and she does
that's what i like about it's moral
clarity and we don't see a lot of it
we don't see a lot of it in these times
but i do think it's important that we
keep
our eye on the prize here which is
the caught the price of fuel and our
ability to have a good summer
and i know the world or well the world
order is being rocked yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah but you know what
how about a fun summer
that we've earned that we didn't have
last summer because of [ __ ] delta
now we're just it's gonna be great cove
is done it's in the rear view
and i think we're just gonna and so i
think that's the real
that's the challenge
how much of your lifestyle are you
willing to sacrifice
i am willing to do what i've done
tweet
post
i'll sign a sternly worded letter
written by barry weiss
but i mean i i you know what i mean
hair is so important keeping your hair
is very important but you got to keep
your hair
that's the best way to do it keeps is a
great product because what it does
is it allows you to prevent hair loss by
keeping the hair that you have
this is the most effective way okay you
can
get keeps you it's a convenient virtual
doctor consultation medication delivered
straight to your door every three months
24 7 care and support they have a
network of expert medical advisors
prescribers and care specialists to
support you in making your hair goals a
reality is low cost okay
they take
um you know the fda
approved medications and they give you
the generic versions of them so
basically you spend a lot less money to
get the exact same results when it comes
to your hair save more and spend less
if you're ready to take action and
prevent hair loss go to k-e-e-p-s dot
com
slash tim dillon to receive your first
month of treatment a friend of mine is
doing this he's doing great he loves it
that's k-e-e-p-s dot com slash tim
dillon to get your first month free
k-e-e-p-s dot com slash
tim dillon
my friend is doing this right now and i
mean he is keeping his hair
he's basically stopped hair loss right
in its tracks
it's amazing
it's kind of like a miracle
do you like miracles
yes
that's right
k-e-e-p-s dot com slash tim dillon
k-e-e-p-s dot com solution keep your
hair
you know where's bird dogs president
zielinski now i know you're all out
there and you want to suck his fat uncut
hog
his fat uncut hose you don't even care
if he washes it first
suck it right from the gym suck his fat
uncut [ __ ] get in there i bet he's got a
big horse [ __ ] and big furry balls and
you don't even care if some of the hairs
get in your mouth or go down your throat
you still keep chugging it jerking the
base and sucking it licking the balls
maybe even lick his tain maybe even eat
his ass it doesn't even matter
you know why because he's got bird dogs
on
and he's doing heroic things in the
ukraine
uh bird dogs are great they're pants you
don't have to wear underwear so if you
want to suck off the president of the
ukraine pull his big [ __ ] out and just
go to town on it i mean swallow every
[ __ ] drip of his gum
take it down
so much of it where in the beginning of
it it's hot but then it's it's there's
so much of it you you look unsure you
take that kind of load from him you know
why because he's got bird dogs on
that's right there's come all over his
stomach you got to suck it out of his
belly button
it's everywhere
bird dogs
president zielinski and then he [ __ ]
you
he after that he's because he's ready to
go again because he's a crazy man yeah
and he's and then he just [ __ ] you raw
he beats it up to the point where you're
grabbing things that don't exist you're
scaling the walls
he's just destroying you
beating every [ __ ] hole
smacking you in the face with it
you're screaming in pain and pleasure
and well why because he has bird dogs on
that's the comfort of built-in underwear
you hero [ __ ] me you hero
that's what you'll yell
as he hits it from the back
smashing you putting your face in the
pillow and maybe biting the back of your
neck
don't stop never stop
go on
uh well i was just sort of explaining uh
what bird dogs are and why i like them
so much yeah
it's the comfort of built in under
finish in my mouth
he goes you want me to come in your
mouth again
yes
never stop
they send me some president zielinski
[ __ ] you
like an animal
i like their designs
they have cool designs like
with the underwear on the inside man
this is on you in the shower afterwards
you feel his warm piss and you go down
and you take it in your mouth like a
golden shower and say hero
maybe give him a blumpkin as he's taking
a big [ __ ]
what are you trying to say well they
have camo ones too the deer hunters oh
good yeah they get them folks they're
good duffy the vampire slayers that's a
cool picture they're good everyone loves
them my wife actually likes them on me
she thinks they're attractive well you
know who she'd really like president
zielinski
she would throw you out of bed real
quick if she could just hop on top of
president zielinski and ride his [ __ ]
until you know would be hot if your wife
[ __ ] zilinski with a gun in her mouth
do you think that would be hot if she
rode zilinski's [ __ ] with a gun in her
mouth and played a little russian
roulette there's one bullet in because
how hot would it be sad because we both
like her but if she blew her brains out
and died as they were both coming
bird dogs tell them the deal what's the
deal here oh yeah so we have a call to
action here so if you go to birddogs.com
and you enter the promo code tim dillon
buy the shorts because they let us say
this yeah
uh we'll see i think they will if they
said anything goes but that was uh that
was a well what does anything ghost mean
well that was sort of a heroic dose of
anything goes like that was well we're
talking about a hero president zielinski
the way he likes to [ __ ] shred bus
and [ __ ]
well sexuality means nothing to him he
just [ __ ] anything
wet or dry
so all you got to do is go to
birddocks.com you enter the promo code
tim dillon and they'll throw in a free
bird dog's whistle football which my dog
likes gracie that's great that dog's an
anxiety filled [ __ ]
that's birddogs.com promo code tim
dillon and boom a free bird dogs
football with your pair of bird dogs you
will not take these things off i promise
you thank you
i wonder if i'm going to do the bitcoin
convention you know we've been playing
chicken with them because i i want more
money and whatever
i don't know if i'm going to go i do
have fun when i go i do like that
community i got to find if i can get a
big guest i don't know if i can get a
big guest i wanted caitlyn jenner that
was my [ __ ] goal and i don't know if
i'm gonna be able to get her i wanted
caitlyn jenner for the bitcoin
conference
logan paul and caitlyn jenner together
was a goal of mine to have
and then this kid will clementi on
twitter is very smart about bitcoin but
i just don't know if i'm gonna get any
of the big names i does it make sense
to go there without the big
names right
no we gotta have caitlyn
i wanted somebody big maybe we could
poop
if i could get putin that would be great
if i could get you know zielinski or
something but i don't want to sit there
and
i need some real [ __ ] star power
to make that conference worth it last
year we had the winklevoss twins who
said a collection of nine words
throughout the hour and jake paul who
talked about wanting to kill dana white
but i was at least funny and the show
was good
i don't know what else i don't know what
we're gonna do this year i don't want to
do stand-up they're doing a comedy tent
i don't want to do that
so i don't i don't know what who i can
bring in
i just don't know
so
you know i'm i'm still up in the air
with this they just sold a house in l.a
called the one
and it's a great story oh they subscribe
to the la times they sold it
um
and
the thing about this house is the
builder
is in a shitload of debt if you go to
the la times article which you're not
subscribed to but i'll give you the time
to subscribe right now for one dollar
for six months
what publications are you subscribed to
for the good of the show
wall street journal i finally signed up
for here's what you no no this is what
you should be subscribed to and i'm not
kidding okay and you can submit this and
i'll pay for it like i do everything
else
here's what you should literally be
subscribed to the new york times the la
times the wall street journal probably
the miami herald chicago tribune
[ __ ] especially because of lightfoot
the chicago tribune
um the boston globe like you should
subscribe like 10 or 20 papers truly
okay you know even the cleveland plain
dealer
because there's stories in there okay
okay you know what i mean but again i
know it's
it's your like how do we
do less spend less do it on the cheap
well this is my one of six free articles
for the month for la times well is that
the way to build a show
into an empire it is not trying to do
have a six free articles no
that's right
thank you
well this article is cool
because the guy
that built this house took a
a 90 million dollar subprime loan
from a company called westlake financial
which does hard money loans which means
loans you can't get in the traditional
banking system
so the developer took this loan and then
he went wild i mean he built this
massive home it's a hundred thousand
square feet
it's grotesque and heinous vulgar
and this guy
then had trouble selling it so then he
was like hey he went to west like
financial he's like
and this guy's a billionaire that is
building the home and he goes well hey
why don't i
why don't i just live in the house and
we'll do i swear to god this is all in
the article he goes we'll do celebrity
boxing events we'll make our money
another way we don't have to sell it we
won't flip it i got in too deep i went
too crazy i spent too much money he goes
we'll do celebrity boxing events and
then we'll do
i'll do the best entertainers in the
world michael jackson whitney houston
and they'll all be holograms
and they'll be holograms
and then people beating the [ __ ] out of
each other
in the backyard and then holograms of
michael jackson of whitney houston
and that's how we'll make our money
instead of flipping the house read a
little bit of the article it's kind of
it is interesting when you get to this
point
where you start building things that are
this big
and again you want to sell it for more
money lift the sanctions
[Music]
okay so the mega mansion known as the
one sold thursday for 126 million at a
bankruptcy auction it's a deal by the
way 126 million for that house is a
steal
it's a steal
126 million it's a good price
it's bel air prime prime prime
that's a huge discount from 295 million
dollar listing price even with a 12
auction fee bringing the total to 141
million
it set a record for the costliest house
sold at auction but it fell well short
of the california sales record set by
venture capitalist mark andreessen who
purchased maui malibu state for 17.7
million so this is still
leagues uh and above wait a minute 17.7
who gives a [ __ ] why is that even in the
article
uh oh they put a period here that's
that's uh it should be 177 million yeah
i don't know why they put a period there
that doesn't make any sense uh the most
ever spent on a u.s residence was 238
million by hedge fund mogul ken griffin
for a new york city penthouse in 2019.
right uh several international sales
have surpassed 300 million though so the
buyer will be disclosed by march 8th
when paperwork must be i hope it's putin
i pray to god it's putin
what a great show putin's in bel air
it says the buyer pool for this is very
small and with everything happening in
russia all of a sudden those russian
billionaires who may have been your best
bet to buy it are pulling out lift the
sanctions
lift the
it's not their fault they own a yacht
it's not their fault putin one little
wacky it's not their fault
is it roman abrama which is bravovich's
fault it's not he's got to sell the
chelsea football club it's not his fault
shout out to roman abramovic
uh it says here the guy who bought it
just got a great deal he's got people
willing to pay fifty thousand dollars a
day just to do commercials and films
i mean that's gonna be a long time to
make your money back that's not a good
deal at all what are you an idiot with
the real chairs yeah well these people
are brand new hanky hanky who's hanky i
don't know who hank oh the largest
creditor is los angeles billionaire don
hanke who yes 106 million to the dream
project of development
[Music]
lender scumbag
who's who's got an office i think in the
valley right
westlake financial west side uh west
lake financial and he's a real old
school scumbag
and he lent this guy 90 million or
something he left lent him exactly 106
million and the lender is owed more than
130 million in secured debt including
money he provided in bankruptcy to
repair and spiff up the property yeah so
they and now who did he lend it to who
did hanky
lend this the developer niall knight
naomi yeah
who's a billionaire in l.a right
i believe he's a developer let me see if
he's a billionaire i don't know if he is
he might not be
i guess he's not
if this is all happening he's an
american former film producer turned
real estate developer who's built and
sold multi-million dollar mansions do
they have a net worth oh you did point
blank interesting let me see his net
worth
net worth and niall's net worth is six
billion yeah he's a billionaire
and they're still fighting over
this and the guy from westlake financial
is also a billionaire
interesting what's his worth don hanke
yeah don hankey
he's just an old school he's one of the
last subprime lenders
hard money baby
god it gives me a hard [ __ ] what a
beautiful thing 5.5 billion so you have
two billionaires fighting over this
house
the the debt
that was lent
to build this by the way go google this
thing it is heinous
and i say that
fully understanding and appreciating how
ostentatious
and vulgar la homes usually are this is
especially grotesque it is ugly in a way
that is hard to describe it is
aesthetically displeasing
it is it is a big waste of money truly
it is it is a big waste of money it is
only for
some
billionaire that wants to say
you know that they own the most
expensive
home in america and obviously this isn't
but it was supposed to be it was listed
for 295 million dollars it was supposed
to be the most expensive home in america
so again who would want that oligarch
you know
a sheik
saudi somebody
chinese amusement park tycoon russian
fertilizer magnet
it's a small buyer's pool but i mean go
look at this house and they call it the
one
it is obnoxious beyond anything that you
can even
it it's not even nice
are you looking at it yeah yeah it's in
the article i mean it's it has like a
moat around it it's like a swimming pool
yeah
and it looks like a mode yeah it's it's
dumb
but i'm rooting for don hankey the hard
money lender yeah so he took over his
father's dealership in 1972 and he built
the hanky group and its main business
being westlake financial services which
makes subprime car loans here's the
thing with a guy like don hankey no
matter how much money he has
they still treat him like scum
like that other guy niall's a developer
and he hangs out with the beautiful
people and don hankey is just he's a
sunburned
low-class scumbag he is actually i'm
looking him up no he's a real drunk
and no matter what he just he's not in
that hollywood glitterati
respected he's an unfortunate looking
guy even though he's a billionaire he's
a used car salesman he's got the stink
of used cars on him and he got swindled
into lending this nile this
hollywood playboy real estate developer
film producer probably just [ __ ] tens
all day and don
hanky
the name hanky sounds like handkerchief
you know he is just but that's why i
root for him because he's just got soot
on his red sunburnt face
and he's just trying to recoup his money
and even though he's a billionaire you
just look at him you go he's one of
those
where they just they don't want him in
the club they don't want him in the
country club they don't want him
anywhere he's got a couple of properties
in malibu but like they don't want him
anywhere
they don't want don hankey
this was expected to hit the market at
500 million when they first built it
they were mentally ill here yeah they
really took a bath here
and the buyer is going to be revealed
march 8th march 8th
who do you think it's gonna be
well it's 105 000 square feet right you
have a big 50-seat theater you have nine
bedrooms multiple kitchens
this is big this is a big big place uh
it's got to be it's got to be so it's
probably not a russian oligarch right
yeah probably not a russian i hope it's
nancy pelosi
it's probably not a russian probably not
a russian it's an arab so it's probably
a saudi it's an arab it may not be a
saudi
could be a qatari
somebody from the united arab emirates
it's an arab
or it's uh somebody from china
but i don't know because
everything but we won't know because
it'll just be the name of their company
their their offshore most likely unless
they want you to know they own it
they may want you to know they own it i
don't know
it's hard for me to know but i do want
to say this
you know i don't trust all the ukrainian
propaganda but this is a legit real
story
david dobrik is fighting with that nazi
regiment in ukraine right now against
the russians
and i think that's pretty [ __ ] cool
to be honest
i think it's pretty [ __ ] cool
that david dobrik right now is embedded
fighting with the as of nazi ukrainian
battalion
i think that's pretty [ __ ] impressive
and frankly
we don't need to go over the fact that
they're nazis what's important is that
they are the elite fighting force of the
ukraine and dobrik one of our best
canceled youtubers has decided
uh to take it upon himself to go fight
with them
to
hold off russia
i think that's pretty impressive don't
you yeah
it's the official position of the tim
dylan show at this juncture to lift all
sanctions
and until september
until after labor day and then we'll
talk about it we'll see what's been done
if putin can't get that place you know
if he can't steamroll them to labor day
i mean come on
if he can't take that by labor day we
got a real problem
and uh i don't know what's gonna happen
a lot of people are gonna be angry with
me because oh you were so sympathetic to
the ukrainians i am
you know how much gas it takes to fill
up a boat
i'm just saying we we can't
we can't throw out the baby with the
bath water
do you get it
do you understand what i mean here or do
i sound like a [ __ ] heartless
psychopath because you know what i don't
think i do i think for the first time in
my life i'm making sense
i mean truly what do you think what do
you feel
uh i think i'm with you but we got to
bring back the sanctions in the fall
though i think it should just be a
seasonal sanction
so
that way
that way they know they got to cool off
at some point and then they can they can
return back to uh the the killing and
the bombing in the in the high season
i
personally
don't love revisiting it before jan
because
no no and you hear me out here
the fall is very very very lovely at the
wineries
there's a lot of bed and breakfast and
then you go right into ski season
i think we do sanctions for the month of
january and february every single year
until they leave ukraine
that's it
that's it
sanctions january and february every
single year until they leave ukraine
yes or yes yeah because it would suck
around christmas if it was just
oh it would really suck yeah
january and february sanctions every
year until they leave ukraine
am i right or am i right
i'm sorry
sorry it's an audio only this week but
we're on tour
and we have
dates coming in nashville
in
jacksonville in
charlotte in new orleans
in dallas in houston in cleveland in
cincinnati
we're shooting this special in march it
won't be out till early may so for the
month of april i'm going to do a lot of
markets i haven't done
and we'll do the show live we've had a
lot of fun with it
and then we will spend the spring and
the summer chilling out podcasting
making some other content working on a
book
hopefully enjoying
but you know again but if we lift the
sanctuaries we got to make a deal about
the gas
we got to make a good deal i mean a good
deal but we're in a position now to make
a really really good deal with him
for cheap
oil daddy
i mean that's the only thing that i can
really think of right now that would
make sense
and it's unfortunate that that's where
we are
but
i also think there's something
about
self-determination
that is very important that we
as a society
have to say there are things we enjoy
and they're things we don't enjoy
and we have to get back to figuring out
how to enjoy more and have more fun
and be less
we we need to bicker less truly
i think instead of fighting about this
war
we ignore it
we remove all sanctions
get cheap gas
and go
swimming
put a couple of dogs and burgers on the
grill
right
you cannot hear carve being shelled over
a kid rock song if you blast it hard
enough
it's time to have the summer we deserve
the summer we've earned
doesn't matter who's right or wrong
doesn't matter
it's time now
it's time to enjoy our summer
we'll revisit this
in january of next year
let's give it a year let's take
a beat
let's take a beat
let's that's the episode title let's
take a beat
because that's what we really have to do
and a lot of people are upset with me
right now because i've solved this
and people hate when i'm right
there's a lot of people out there that
don't like when i'm right they go oh boy
that's uncomfortable comedian write
again solving world issues again
but what do you not want me to do it
you want me to leave it up to these
scumbags in congress i've just done it
take an 11 month pause here
on this
and let's enjoy ourselves
let's enjoy ourselves in the spoils
what good is an empire if you can't even
have fun
if we're gonna live in this morally
compromised hellscape
that was built on the blood and bones of
people can't we enjoy it
thanks for listening